you run linkedin influencers that's
right I want to know what the big guys
are saying about this watch well I think
first of all to sing a lot of things
number one you heard Tim Cook talk a
little bit about this is the most
personal device I've ever created this
idea of your personal data is a very big
idea what happens now that Apple knows
so much about you what happens to that
data David Kirkpatrick one of the
influencers wrote a great piece last
night saying this is a luxury device and
what Apple is good at is creating luxury
for the masses they basically gave a
smartphone that everyone can have my
smartphone is as good as Elon Musk's
smartphone but the watch is different
they are saying if you buy a
ten-thousand-dollar watch will have this
amazing experience is beautiful the
aluminum you know sits on your wrist
nicely and that's not the way Apple
typically plays the game what does it
mean that they're getting into this very
high-end business and how will it play
out a lot of questions about that a lot
of influence are saying don't buy this
watch right now wait really why why is
that okay the coach dummies nag it's
good you know it's not gonna work well
and and how do you upgrade it isn't even
upgrade of course unclear and that was
always my question is the upgrade cycle
right we do that with our iphones it
with our macbooks is that a concern that
all of a sudden what people will buy now
will be obsolete in a few years
absolutely yeah and you're not seeing
what you didn't hear today was anything
about how long they expect this to last
how when you know they obviously
wouldn't say what the upgrade cycle is
but I mean this is a watch that maybe at
best we'll get 18 hours a day in a
single charge what's going to happen
when the next one has a much better
battery life you're going to give this
thing back for four hundred dollars you
know there's no are the carrier is going
to subsidize this that doesn't look like
Lisa try to buy this watch it's a good
question and you were raising the point
about how it's now luxury market the
gold watch you could argue is more of a
fashion statement I mean are you hearing
different types of people talking about
the Apple watch on linkedin so we've had
170 posts in the last week alone on the
Apple watch these are just members
writing about what's going on we've got
1200 since sep tember people are very
curious about this but the the feelings
basically run the are on either side of
the spectrum some people are Apple fans
and they are ready to buy there are a
lot of marketers talking about how are
they going to mark it on the face of the
watch this will change how you do
marketing and a lot of people saying
this is my data I don't want Apple
having it
I want to be stuck with something that
looks beautiful and becomes
non-functional in six months the other
news that we did here they haven't
talked about yet is that HBO going to
partner with Apple TV so you can kind of
get your own HBO app on Apple TV did
people seem to care about that yeah I
really am seeing anything today about
that but people care deeply about being
able to do over the top TV that's
something that we get posted out a lot
there is this idea of cord cutting how
are you going to do it an apple just
announced they're gonna make it much
easier um the other interesting post i
thought was Carlos gone the CEO of
Nissan wrote at the end of last week he
just came back from the geneva auto show
and said that the question he got asked
most often was how was he throwing about
the apple cart reuse oh not the Apple
watch the Apple car and his point of
view was great and if you think about
what David Kirkpatrick said which is
apple takes big ideas and they spread
under the world the Apple car fits that
mold more than the watch this idea if
Apple can come through with a car and I
know I'm already on to apples next
announcement but if they can come
through with a car that is for the
masses but does incredible things that
will change the face of the auto
industry and so Carlos going to saying
that's great he doesn't see it as a
competitor bring it so does he see an
actual car that Apple makes or does he
see a car that Nissan makes that Apple
has control of all the guts inside the
technology it's not saying exactly
what's going on but he's saying that
whatever they do he's fine as long as it
ties him with a zero-emission idea and
he doesn't believe Apple will do a car
that isn't zero emission or friendly to
the environment I think that's probably
what everyone agrees if they're gonna go
the car route if not if it's just the
guts of the car different story and you
hear anything really quickly on the
research kit with apple announced today
the sort of giving over your medical
information yeah if they're scared about
privacy there or that hasn't come up so
far what you're saying or people in the
medical world saying this is great the
more information you have the better but
we always see doctors writing saying you
know this is it's terrifying when you
have patients coming in saying here's a
report i've read over you know WebMD
here's the information that I just got
from my SmartWatch am i dying doctor